[Musique]
j'ai toujours eu les meilleures sa
tension
quelqu'un incendié votre maison sachant
que vous étiez à l'intérieur
lna connaissez vous quelqu'un qui aurait
pu faire ça le loyer de 300 dollars par
mois ce qui est très en dessous du
marché
de toute façon avec mon mari on ne fait
pas ça pour l'argent et acceptait de lui
louer sans garantie danser un peu plus
sur elle vous travaillez dans quoi je
suis artiste va proposer à cette femme
de venir travailler chez nous c'est très
valorisant de savoir que vos actions
peuvent embellir la vie d'une autre
personne
c'est difficile pour toutes les mères
quand il ya de l'argent ça se voit moins
mais il ya une chose qu'on ne peut pas
acheter
c'est l'amour d'une mère pourquoi tu
détache pas tes cheveux maman c'est de
loin son meilleur atout alors comme ça
il n'y a que vous dit où on déménage
souvent pour le boulot de ma mère elle
cache des trucs tout le monde a ses
petits secrets
j'ai contacté la personne que vous avez
cités comme étant votre ancien
propriétaire sur le bail et bizarrement
il a dit qu'il ne vous connaissais pas
si tu veux vivre dans ma maison tu dois
respecter mes règles
qui est d'étudier l'accepter sans rien
dieu si toi tu ne fais rien pour
défendre ses actuels qui le fera qu'elle
est profondément à filtrer dans notre
vie j'ai besoin de savoir qui est
vraiment cette femme
[Musique]
on a tous des pardons qui me ses frais
tu vraiment prêt pouvant cacher cette
histoire
[Musique]
auquel on essaie d'échapper tu m'as
jamais dit la vérité sur rien
[Musique]
des parties de nous mêmes que nous
refusons de voir tu perds complètement
ton sang-froid t'inquiète pas je suis
parfaitement calme
monde finira par payer pour ce qu'il a
fait
je suis au courant de votre petit secret
est ce que c'est une menace